so essentially what we're trying to do
is build a secure cloud computing
platform
um and what we really do is we can model
our model computation revolves around
the finite State machine and so a client
which is a computationally weak
um entity like wants to off board
offload this combination to a server so
it can essentially encrypt the function
it wants to apply and encrypt the data
streams and it forwards into the server
what's the server then applies to the
data and returns with a response that's
uh that's unforgeable essentially like
um it is impossible for someone to try
and pretend as if they executed the
computation
so here's like a general overview of the
protocol where
the client forwards the encrypted
function and then forwards any number of
data streams where the server then
applies it and returns with a response
and this has many applications to
um well one particular one is regex
regular Expressions can be implemented
State machines and a lot of like spam
filtering and malware detection is a lot
of times really complex
regular Expressions so by doing this you
can off-board the
basically the decision of whether or not
a program is malicious or not and one of
kind of like the ways we'll be doing
this or like using this in practice is
our first application to software to
find Networks
in this model you have a bunch of
routers in the field
and they eat each of their routing
systems is independently controlled by
the controller so in this model the
communication between the node and the
server is encrypted using the secure
Cloud computation platform so if a
packet enters that could be malicious
the node forwards it to the server and
says hey is this packet suspicious
um if so if this were entirely
unencrypted someone could respond say no
it's not and then the packet's now in
the network and can get on the other
nodes but in this model the server
doesn't know uh what function it's
Computing or the data that was passed so
it would be impossible for someone to
just say yes or no in response